[موسيقى]
لا أستطيع تذكر اللحظة الأولى
بعد الانهيار لأنني ضربت
رأسي ولم أكن
أه لا أستطيع تذكر بعض الأشياء ولكن
أه ذاكرتي الأولى في دائرة المستشفى
أتذكر الألم في ظهري
وكانت المشكلة أن
كان الدواء جديدًا بالنسبة لي ، لذلك ذهبت
بشكل أسرع مما كان ممكنًا في إحدى
الزوايا وخرجت من الحصى
ثم تحطمت وأنا في الحصى ،
لذا
لم يكن حادثًا كبيرًا بالتأكيد
ربما كان حادثًا غبيًا
ولكني اعتقدت  حول التأخر وبالطبع لقد
استمتعت كثيرًا بهذه الفرشاة الغبية
كنت مع والدي هنا
والتقط الصورة لأنني طلبت منه أن يفعل
ذلك
ليرى كيف كانت هذه السيارة لقد
أريتها للتو
لأنني أعتقد أن  من الجيد أن تكون وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
قريبة من المعجبين ،
فنحن دائمًا نعرض اللحظات الجيدة التي يمكنهم
رؤيتها على التلفزيون ،
حيث يفوز الدراجون في السباقات ويمرحون ، ولكن
وراء كل هذه الأشياء ، يتعين على الكتاب
أن
يمروا ببعض اللحظات الصعبة خلال
جميع المهن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق
] بدأت في الحصول على c  خسرت في
تدريبي المعتاد بعد
أربعة أشهر في يناير ، كان علي أن
أقترح مرة أخرى
إخراج كل اللوحات
وكل ما لدي في الحقيبة
ثم بدء التعافي مرة أخرى
ولكن الثانية كانت أسهل قليلاً
لأننا  كنت أعرف ماذا أفعل أعرف أن
السباق ليس آمنًا ،
إنها رياضة خطيرة للغاية ولكنها
الحياة التي أختارها
وأنا أعلم أن شيئًا ما يمكن أن يحدث ولكنك
لا تعرف أبدًا
أين يمكن أن يحدث ،
لذلك أحاول أن أستمتع حتى  أكثر من ذي
قبل لأنني أشعر أن
لدي فرصة ثانية للقيام
بما أحب
المكان المناسب الذي
اتصلت به ، أعتقد أن سبعة أو
ثمانية مغيرين
في الزوايا الأربع الأخيرة ، سيحتلون
المركز الثاني
بكل تأكيد ، كل النتائج الجيدة بالنسبة لي في ذلك السباق ،
لكن الفوز كان أفضل بالنسبة لي
للفريق
وكان من الجيد حقًا
كن مصدر إلهام لبعض الناس
لدي شيء
مشابه مثلي لأنني إذا عدت إلى
السباق وأصبحت صديقة للبيئة بالتأكيد يمكن للجميع
التعافي
والعودة إلى حياتهم الطبيعية
[موسيقى]